there's a reason why I'm doing this
chiffon cakes need to be hey guys I
think as you guys know I love making
trendy food and I love trying foods from
different parts of the world
specifically I want to try and recreate
some of the most viral cakes around the
world this time my brother challenge
needs to make this boba tea lava cake
from Taiwan here's the thing I know this
cake I have seen this cake many a times
- on my Instagram and it is the cake
that I was like there's no way I'm
making this happen but I can't let him
know that and so here we are and I'm
gonna figure it out
Skylar come on in tell us I mean that is
you good times good times
tell me about this cake okay so it's
basically a chocolate lava cake but not
really because instead of the chocolate
inside it is boba on top of the cake
what the whole like rap kind of thing
and when you pull it up everything's are
dropping where did you first see this
cake I saw it like on Instagram and
YouTube on Facebook mostly on the
instrumental longer yeah there's a lot
why do you want me to make this cake
really the only person that I can ask to
make this bakery Johnny yeah eight hours
all right
challenge accepted let's get started
okay
coffee all right we have a lot to do so
let's do it there's a couple things we
need to do there is the cake itself
which I'm gonna do as a chiffon cake
cuz it's spongy its fluffy its soft the
lava cream and then there is also the
boba so I'm gonna start by doing the
cake cuz that needs to bake and then it
needs to cool chiffon cake it is I have
a recipe here nobody see it it's my
mom's secret chiffon cake recipe hers
was in Chinese so I translated it to
English the first thing I need to do is
to make the Earl Grey milk which is
going to be the base of the cake and
it's going to give it that
wonderful Earl Grey tea flavor my
brother really likes Earl Grey tea might
give me bonus points I'm just going to
pour the milk in cook this on low heat
while the heat is milking up while the
milk is heating up I am going to cut a
few bags of tea four bags boom okay the
milk doesn't have to be boiling you just
want it to be hot enough where the tea
can steep in it properly what am i doing
well this is waiting and it can be so
much more useful I'm gonna separate the
eggs in here nice I know some people
they just like put them all in one bowl
and then scoop out the yolks with their
hands I like to live on the edge so I
can smell the milk milk please hold just
got it good right here what do you call
this chaotic energy here we are we
cracked all our eggs milk is now ready
my hands are not ready though so give me
one second I'm gonna turn this off you
can feel that it's super warm
just sprinkle this in there give it a
little stir smells like milk tea already
oh there's no so good covered this up
and set this aside basically you're just
gonna let this tea steep until the milk
becomes cool again this is all good
let's get the meringue going stand mixer
I'm gonna have to add in the cream of
tartar and then we have some sugar oh
that's going in the background let me
just clear this up a little bit looking
good that's exciting
tea still smells amazing you see how the
color is changing a little bit I'm just
breaking up the egg yolks most of the
air will be coming from the meringue
mixture but you still want to beat these
a little bit put the sugar we're
actually supposed to put the milk into
the egg yolk mixture if your milk is too
hot you're gonna end up with scrambled
eggs in your cake and nobody wants that
I think we're good to pour it out can
deceive squeeze all of it out Earl Grey
milk can I just drink it like this
definitely very ill great I like that
and the temperature is good now gonna
pour this milk in slowly can you see the
color becoming a little lighter oh it's
pretty good
we can add in the cake flour and baking
powder stir it all together
looking good so far I'm gonna add the
oil slowly but surely helps make it a
little lighter and texture keeps it
moist as people like to say it's looking
pretty smooth yeah a little bit ribbony
room the right truck there let's get
folding we could eat this is gonna
gently fold this in now oh yeah you can
feel how soft it is they're trying to be
really careful here and not like beat
the air out too nice color too we're
making sure everything's combined evenly
oh that was satisfying I can feel how
Airy this is and it's so smooth cannot
wait to eat this you don't want to mix
it too much because otherwise there's
not gonna be any air left
as long as it's combined you don't see
like random streaks in places we're good
to put it in the cake mold yeah this is
so light it weighs like nothing I have a
second one I'm just trying to be safe at
least there's another one for backup but
also if both of them work and I'll take
the bigger one and my brother will take
the smaller one
I have my two key geese opens already
been preheated so I'm just gonna go
ahead and pop them in there now and
we'll check on it later cakes are in the
oven now we move on to the cream part
the star of the dish so I can't say for
sure that I know exactly what was in it
but I am gonna use like a heavy cream
base to give it that like fluffy foamy
consistency the flavor is also important
so I am going to start by making an Earl
Grey pastry cream that I've done before
that hopefully can give it that flavor
that color that smooth texture over here
I'm just reheating the milk a little bit
egg yolks that I have pre cracked sugar
give this a good stir
lots of beating and whisking today it's
getting lighter though add the cake
flour a nice little mixture here it's
almost like making a cake again this
kiss Oh we're in a bit of trouble
[Music]
well
[Music]
chicken oh my god you're gonna come see
we're in a bit of a dilemma because I'm
still making the pastry cream but this
needs to be out before it overcook so I
need to take this Mullin out now cups
look like I'm crazy but I promise this
is for a reason
oh yeah wow it's like a little mushroom
it's a cute little muffin top okay this
is a tricky part because it's hot and I
need to invert it on top of this oh boy
okay this is there's a reason why I'm
doing this chiffon cakes need to be hold
on this is a two-person job
but I will do it I will make it happen
oh my god we did it oh let me explain
what I just did there I didn't have
enough time to explain it but the reason
we need to invert it immediately is
because we don't do that the chiffon
cake will kind of sink back down and you
won't get that kind of volume that you
want my mom told me to do this and it
works so I mean we failed a couple times
definitely a little bit more squish than
it should be but it's out now we just
need to let it cool we're just gonna
pour the rest of this in now now that
this has been combined this is going
back on the stovetop gotta get the
second cake out Wow oh it smells so good
oh my god all right
second one is now out and invert it they
look really good I'm really nervous I
hope that means we're on the right track
now we keep this up we're just gonna
cook this down until it becomes like a
paste this will become our Earl Grey
concentrate that will later whip into
the whipping cream
make it super tasty don't they look so
pretty that volume on it that means the
air really went through that's really
exciting
now the problem really is more just to
make sure it comes out that way
it's been many many minutes I've been
just stirring and cooking this on low
heat my patience has paid off let me
show you guys maybe not that visual but
it's so goopy this is what we're looking
for a beautiful sort of thick Earl Grey
paste let it cool I'm gonna give this a
little taste
[Music]
wait that's so good it's like really
creamy and the Earl Grey flavor really
comes through now we're gonna set this
aside and we went to the next step which
is to cook the whole one to cook the
boba we're moving along we are back
let's talk boba this time I decided to
make my own boba and you can see that
they're a little less dark in color I
just figured since I'm making everything
else from scratch I build I should be
from scratch too but we'll save the
process of doing that for another video
these are my little little babies these
ones will take a little longer to cook
let it cook like this for a 15 minute
and rest for 30 minutes very soft and
gooey now I'm just going to scoop some
brown sugar this is what gives it that
like brown sugar syrupy molasses flavor
just sweetening the boba a little bit
this sugar water will cook down slowly
into a sugar syrup that will really
complement our Earl Grey cream so while
that's cooking off to the side I think
it's time to take the cakes out of the
mold
wish me luck this is the make-or-break
moment I am super nervous I mean that
came out beautiful oh it's so cool it
looks very different from when I first
pulled it out I'm just going to slowly
cut the sides and it's okay the top can
fall off
ready
okay he's a little messy but so there's
a huge hole here this is not part of the
plan okay
nothing a little bit of trimming won't
fix it is very very fluffy so that's
good and super soft
flavor-wise it's super good just doesn't
get any points for looks looks like a
little volcano right now which is I
guess on brand right hopefully this one
looks better than the other one wait
what to do
did it do it all over again this is not
the cake I was most it is a card full
everything's falling apart ah I kind of
don't want to show this to camera what
did I do wrong can I even stand on
itself
absolutely not I was really hoping this
will work I think I need to redo
everything again okay I'm gonna call my
mom
cuz moms know best already sent her a
picture you see me so disappointed okay
way okay then I will try again okay bye
got a few tips I'm gonna do this all
over again next time you see me I will
have a cake I will make my mom proud all
right let's cut we have a cake I have
already trimmed it as you've already
seen a really ugly cake we are finally
able to move on to our cream this is our
beautiful pastry cream which has now
cooled I say beautiful but it's not the
most beautiful looking thing and that's
okay you don't always have to be
beautiful to be tasty I've got me some
whipping cream and sugar just gonna whip
that right up this is honestly the part
where we do not have a recipe at all at
this point I am just trying to recreate
that love a cream based on what I know
of how whipped cream works this whipping
has to be really really really soft
that's the only way it will fall
hopefully we get this on first try based
on what we've seen with the cake that is
not looking too good but one can dream I
am going to test it on the cake pan that
we used earlier it has to be safe wrap
right around it like so this is what we
have super liquidy which is exactly what
we want it's makes this in first just
combining the two to flavor this cream I
want it to be at a consistency where I
can pour it right on it needs to look
like lava needs to run like lava add
more liquid we're getting there
horrible nice temp to number one feel
like it's too thick
no a little more cream maybe there we go
that's what I'm talking about
there enough for it to fall over this is
a really creamy cake moment of truth
will it pour
[Music]
this is so exciting let's make the cake
fun cake
building time I'm excited the cream has
worked let's get started get Trix see
this is what happens when I get too
excited I'm really nervous this is it I
don't have another cake if I don't do it
I'm done if I fail this it's not just
failing the Internet my brother will
never let this go that's a good
consistency okay let's go I think that's
a good amount of cream and I'm gonna put
the boba in what's not staying on top
it's because it's too hot right now if
we blow some air on it he'll be fine
right right this is what it's come down
to I'm so worried told myself I only had
one shot and here I am the boba cake
tada
it looks pretty legit right smells
amazing I am going to call Skylar over
and then we're gonna do the friend
reveal together please work come on in
what do you think this is like the most
unimpressed face ever there's no like
wow wow it looks so good no this looks
like a good thing really yeah you're not
just saying that no I'm so surprised you
want to do the pool three two one go
[Music]
I was good I was so nervous but it came
right over right like in the videos i
bask in my glory for like two seconds
high-five myself thank you I'm so happy
I got a knife no I got a fork no I
couldn't fork and a knife so soft
no more boba please that's a good slice
and you're going in for like more bites
I'm so impressed by myself right now
I would imagine we did it well I did it
solid eight point why is it eight seven
nine out of ten is a copy long dress it
mean you got to be a little bit more
original sometimes you know I'm glad you
finally got to try this I know you've
been wanting to transfer a long time if
any of you out there have like a viral
cake that you know of from your country
send it to me leave a comment below send
me a DM let's try to make it happen I
want to make it happen are you okay you
got it alright see you next time
[Music]